lined it up but couldn't knock down the
three Edwards pulled the trigger from
the s in March Madness Carson Edwards
this is the way Old Dominion played in
the Conference USA tournament as AdWords
hits the 313 sit back i furred poked it
away
AdWords pull up triple Carson Edwards
Villanova Silk Road is the three-point
shooting around the revamped e block and
the lane opens up Edwards tries to the
gap drills it back into the hands of
Edwards parson Edwards step back on City
pay how tough is that one
[Applause]
threes in the game and 33 on the board
for Carson Edwards we're do over at
Muroc somehow it gets past Gillespie
Purdue's roster 15 threes in the game to
do they average 10 best in the big 10 of
Matt Peterson Samuels
arms keeps alive into the hands of
carsonfp tapped it to Carson who's
[Applause]
display
he Bowden leads all Tennessee scores
with ten about Tennessee they're going
to his own now never since first it did
some adjustment and he has helped
Tennessee fight their way back the
Suffolk led by Tennessee shot clock at
seven here's Edwards for three carson
Edwards the scoring leader in the big
ten time they have a great play they
come to come and do something different
on the table roughness beautiful finish
parson Edwards
here's that works
son of a cloud deandre hunter averaging
15 point 2 points per game in the
regular season he led Virginia scoring
Edwards cocaine
gone big against the Boilermakers
receive Purdue right now whose hecklers
off the ball or in the pick-and-roll to
get him a little action he has to get
going
[Applause]
never shoot the gap on the shooter when
you have two screens coming he gave back
to three he just knocked a head where
it's a low
[Applause]
nothing but net East his men saw just to
come in when you have your teammate
having a pump it's a good position
where's any Tommy has to rock with a lot
gible behind the three-point line
is it good position this is a threat to
China or knock it down
melts when Purdue needs to stick to what
works for them either head Edwards climb
or go inside Edwards for three yes he's
got nine threes anchored the defense in
the paint for the offensive acre let's
see if you get back in the pick-and-roll
get hammers son and Edwards
then you may double-team him the bigs
have to be ready to slip the
pick-and-roll right away and have their
hands ready to catch
here's Edwards for the leap
[Applause]
it's it right back now Edwards on the
take Edwards gets in the lane
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]